an regeln an die wir uns jetzt
neuerdings zu halten haben und an die
bei uns halten
wir müssen denn sonst gibt es strafen
frank schneider ist mit dem ordnungsamt
heute unterwegs und frank polizei
ordnungsamt sie sind tatsächlich
angehalten und so hat es die kanzlerin
ja gestern auch noch mal deutlich gesagt
diese regeln auch durchzusetzen wie
funktioniert das bei dir das
funktioniert wirklich erstaunlich gut
muss man sagen hinter mir sieht man das
sagen
das ordnungsamt ist es wird hier vom
ordnungsamt kontrolliert und nicht von
der polizei
momentan ist es auch völlig ausreichen
weil die menschen sind wirklich sehr
einsichtig merkels in der stadt man
sieht sehr wenig menschen selbst hier im
park ist es heute traumhaftes wetter
sonnenschein und strahlend blauer himmel
sieht man wirklich nur zweier gruppen
oder menschen die mal kurz mit dem hund
gassi gehen
es gab eben zwei junge männer die mir
ball gekickt haben aber auch wirklich
nur zu zweit die sind daneben aber auch
wieder gegangen als die leute halten
sich wirklich wenn es geht drinnen auf
muss wirklich sagen sie sind einsichtig
werden eben einen fall da hatte einen
kiosk geöffnet das darf er auch aber
hatte draußen noch ein stehtisch er
wusste nicht dass er den weg räumen
osterstein vier männer dran
die dann zwar meinten sie hätten genug
abstand ihr auch schon ein bisschen was
getrunken hätten habe es dann aber auch
eingesehen und sind dann artig mit ihrer
flasche bier alle nach hause gegangen
und da reicht dann eben auch mal eine
mündliche verwarnung weil es ganz
offensichtlich war die waren sich ihrer
schuld nicht bewusst und frank generell
wenn du dich umschaute wird tatsächlich
darauf geachtet also achten die menschen
selber drauf auf den abstand auf die
menge an personen mit denen sie
unterwegs sind funktioniert das ist da
sagen wir mal die selbstkontrolle
tatsächlich aktiv heute ja absolut
das haben auch die beinamen gesagt das
ordnungsamt ist mit denen wir unterwegs
sind im vergleich zur letzten woche ist
das ein unterschied wie tag und nacht
letzte woche war es völlig uneinsichtig
die menschen überhaupt nicht eingesehen
die saßen in straßencafés noch draußen
dabei die gastronomie in großen teilen
auch noch geöffnet das war ein komplett
anderer zustand jetzt haben die menschen
ist wirklich offenbar kapiert und
eingesehen und wie gesagt es ist
traumhaft schönes wetter und die straßen
und auch hier die parks und und die
spielplätze normale abgesperrt das ist
alles wirklich komplett leer und die
menschen scheinen kapiert zu haben
das ist wirklich gefährlich ist und dass
wir jetzt alle zusammenhalten müssen uns
an diese vorschriften und regeln halten
müssen damit es eben funktioniert und in
deutschland eben nicht so eine pandemie
ausbricht wie eben in italien momentan
auch in spanien franken jeder ist
glücklich der ein balkon hat der kann
nämlich das gute wetter genießen und
sich an die so wichtigen regeln halten
vielen dank frank schneider